SPEAKER: In this
video, we'll talk
about how to use Google
Cloud Pub/Sub to enable
real-time developer
notifications
for your subscriptions.
For more information about how
to set up Google Cloud Pub/Sub,
go here.
Unlike the Google
Play Developer API--
which requires
you, the developer,
to send requests to Google--
Cloud Pub/Sub works
the other way around,
sending information
from Google to you.
When does this happen?
Anytime a subscription
entitlement changes,
such as subscription
renewal, cancellation,
or if the user has entered a
grace period or account hold.
With real-time
developer notifications,
you'll receive a purchase token
directly from Cloud Pub/Sub
anytime there is an update
to an existing subscription.
This purchase token
doesn't contain
the details of the change.
So you'll need to send
the purchase token
from your secure back end to
the Google Play Developer API
to get the updated information
attached to the purchase token.
Once verified, you will
have the revised information
about the subscription, which
can be stored on your back end
server as well as sent
to your Android app
if needed to ensure
users have access
to the appropriate in-app
content and services.
And that's it.
By enabling real-time
developer notifications,
you are able to stay up-to-date
on your users' subscription
status.
If you'd like to learn more,
be sure to visit the link
onscreen, or check out
our other videos here.